wer dort etwas gemacht dass meine
freundin ist zum glück nicht so aber es
gibt genug mädchen von congstar die
abscheidung leiter des company of heroes
ist heute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ich
jemals wieder auf einem kanal und soja
ich krieg seit längerer zeit schon immer
mal wieder nen achten auf facebook die
mir schreiben ja mach doch mal ein video
und autos bei typen nervös weil frauen
und jahres mafia oder am stand mehrere
youtuber gehört habe ich mir wieder acht
abkommen du hast du nicht so wirklich
eine idee und du musst auch spontan ein
video machen das macht das jetzt
natürlich auch spontan für euch und
ja-wort geht's einfach mal um logos no
no go's also es geht auf jeden fall um
logos bei mädchen bei frauen keine
ahnung ich hab mir das einfach überlegt
was ich so ziemlich scheiße finde ab
turnt oder wie man das nennt
auf jeden fall wünsche euch viel spaß
mit dem video und ja plötzlich gefällt
geben daumen hoch oder rein bei uns
jetzt schon keine ahnung viel spaß so
fangen wir an mit nummer eins und zwei
sich bei mir so wenn ich jetzt gerade
mädchen sehr die irgendwo stehen und es
ist egal rauchen keine ahnung einfach so
gut worauf so durch die nase kommt und
dadurch den mund l war er siebter sieg
weil bei jungs geht das noch finde ich
aber wenn du mädchen sie ist sie dann da
so rauchen oder wo halt einfach so bald
keine arbeit finden ist bei mir einfach
so also ich weiß nicht wie das andere
jungs sehen ob die das geil finden wenn
jetzt ihre freundin raucht oder she shot
keine ahnung auf jeden fall finde ich
das irgendwie total eklig schreibt doch
einfach mal eure meinung dazu und in die
kommentare
würd mich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
interessieren was andere jungs oder wie
die darüber denken so und dann geht es
weiter
was ich auch überhaupt nicht verstehen
kann bzw was die auch einfach total
scheiße finde es gibt ja genug mädchen
die sind bei jeder scheiße sauer egal
was du machst das jetzt machen dass
meine freundin ist zum glück nicht so
aber es gibt genügend mädchen die so
sind wie ich es auch immer wieder mit
kriege und wenn du so ein mädchen hast
oder so eine freundin und egal was du
machst du schreibst einfach du leisten
ins bild von einem anderen mädchen und
dieser dann fragt man sich was ist mit
der falsche
so und dann geht es auch schon weiter
auf jeden fall ich persönlich krieg das
auch andauernd mit vor allem auf
facebook jetzt irgendwelche von euch
jetzt sind jetzt nicht der großteil ich
würde mal sagen 25 prozent oder so wenn
irgendwas kommentieren oder so oder wenn
ich mit irgendwelchen mädchen von euch
manchmal schreibe so hellmann machst du
blablabla oder so dann kommen da so
nachrichten oder da denkst du dir wie so
könnt ihr nicht in ganzen sätzen
schreiben beziehungsweise warum schreibt
ihr so wie ich meine wenn jetzt irgendwo
so ein mädchen kommentieren sie ist kopf
gegen wand junger bruder verraten ich
leider schon wieder auf aber es ist
wirklich so manche mädchen schreibt so
ein scheiß da denkt man sich dann
irgendwie gehen nicht zur schule oder so
können sie sich nicht vernünftig
ausdrücken auf jeden fall schätze ich
mal dass es irgendwie kein jungen gibt
es ja sowas geil findet oder irgendwie
wenn doch dann schreibt es auch auf
jeden fall mal bitte unten in die
kommentare
und dann habe ich zum schluss etwas und
zwar es gibt ja auch genug mädchen die
lachen entweder bei jeder scheiß egal
was jemand macht oder die berühren nicht
so ein ganz bisschen beschuldigung das
ist zwar herzlich schlimm oder so aber
irgendwann kann es einem dann glaube ich
echt aussehen wenn man jetzt die
freundin hat oder so also meine freundin
ist wie gesagt nicht so aber es gibt
bestimmt genug freundinnen die dann halt
bei jeder scheiße oder irgend was du
machst du bewegst dich nur
so leute und das war dann jetzt
eigentlich auch schon so alle punkte die
ich mir gerade so spontan überlegt habe
auf jeden fall hoffe ich natürlich
dieses video häufig wie mal gefallen ich
habe jetzt bald 3000 abonnenten deswegen
würde mich freuen wenn ihr kräftig doch
abonnieren würdet wenn es euch gefallen
hat das video dann gebt einfach mal
daumen hoch schreibt sohn in die
kommentare
keine ahnung alle links zu instagram und
chor findet ihr natürlich und in der
video beschreibung hier unten links geht
jetzt weiter mit meinem letzten video
das war der golf renntag mit meiner
freundin unten rechts geht's zu dem
video dinge die mädchen einen jungen
nicht verstehen ja genau so rum auf
jeden fall
wir sehen uns dann nächste woche wieder
leider fängt die schule bei mir jetzt
wieder an keine ahnung ich weiß ja nicht
wie es bei euch ist auf jeden fall
schönen samstag noch schönes wochenende
hat rein